I pleased introduce Leonard Mlodinow off today.
He's a theoretical physicist who is good at making complex scientific topics
interesting and easy to understand.
He has five New York Times bestsellers,
including subliminal and the grand design,
which he wrote together with Stephen Hawking among other TV shows.
He wrote First Star Trek,
the next generation.
He's had numerous contributions to various publications,
including the New York Times,
the Wall Street Journal,
Scientific American,
as well as appearances on a range of TV shows from morning show to through the
wormhole.
Please join me in giving him a warm welcome.
[inaudible] thanks for taking your time to come here.
Because I had a little tour and I know you could be at the gym,
you could be having Sushi,
could be out walking around and like a nice campus.
So wow.
It's better be good.
David
all depends on how on the moderator.
So if he's good,
it'll be good.
No pressure.
So,
um,
your book is about elastic thinking.
What do you mean by elastic thinking?
Well,
I just did
Mr between two different types of thinking,
analytical or logical thinking,
which computers are really good at.
Uh,
which you can use to execute algorithms and it's very valued in society,
sat tests for the employers,
your employers maybe not Google because they know better about your employers
generally just look for that.
And then there's a elastic thinking,
which is more of a bottom up process.
It's where ideas come from and it's not how you follow rules,
but it's how you come up with rules,
how you get ideas or imagination,
creativity,
how you're integrating different,
um,
knowledge from different areas,
make new associations.
And so this,
we need both and most of what we do and my book is about how the last tech
thinking arises in your brain and the psychology of and how you can nurture it.
And um,
so you couldn't use your rational,
logical thinking to figure out the best way to go to the groceries to drive to
the grocery store.
But it's the elastic picking deck.
Got Someone's who's been in the car.
So that's how I described.
Cool.
Um,
also in the gym,
in,
in addition to elastic thinking,
analytical thinking,
you talk about autopilot and how some of our lives we do on the autopilot.
Can you give some?
I say it's not thinking,
it's just a matter of definition,
but when I looked in various dictionaries that neuroscience books,
this kind of information processing that the brain does,
did not seem to be qualify as thinking,
and it's really a very simple rule base.
Little outgrown that where there's a trigger in your environment that causes you
to do something and then you execute that without even processes.
They get very deeply having any novelty or any kind of flexibility in your
brain.
One example is when you drive to work on autopilot,
your,
your body and your mind are just following the path that you follow every day.
With me,
sometimes if I'm going somewhere or if I used to be driving somewhere that was
near Caltech,
I would start off on my way to Caltech countryside realize I'm in cal tech,
but that's not where I was going to get up because I'm on autopilot and these
triggers,
this stop sign means to turn left.
You know that red light means turn right and then I'm at the wrong place.
And it's been shown that by psychologists that that these kinds of automatic
scripts are fixed action patterns of psychologists call them our injustice for
trivial things like driving to work.
We actually engage in a lot of our social interpersonal reactions that way.
For instance,
people with their significant other or their spouse,
sometimes one says something which triggers the other.
And pretty soon you're on the same kind of an argument pathway that,
that you have done to way too many times before and you know,
you don't want to do what do you keep doing it?
Um,
one other less emotional example was a very famous study done by Ellen Langer,
who is one of my heroes,
psychologists at Harvard.
She stationed someone near a xerox machine.
And when someone came up to use the copier,
this confederate would walk up to the machine and say one of three different
things.
So one thing that,
that person would say that some of them said was,
excuse me,
can I get in front of you?
I have to xerox five pages and I'm in a hurry.
Another way to say it was,
excuse me,
can I get in front of you?
She uses xerox machine and then she compared the,
uh,
the compliance rates of the two.
And the people who gave the reason that they're in a hurry,
they got 95% of people allow them to do that.
And the people who didn't give a reason,
it was at 60% pretty agreeable,
but it was a big difference.
Then she had done another way.
The person would walk up to the,
well,
what she was asking was,
are these people taking into account this reason that this person's in a hurry,
processing it intelligently and then decided,
okay,
they're in a higher rate.
I'm not,
I'll let them in.
Or are they just following some kind of social script?
Well,
she had a person to go up and ask you in another way,
they would say,
excuse me,
can I get in front of you?
And I have,
um,
can I get in front of you because I have five pages to xerox.
So now they're giving a reason,
but it's adding,
it's adding no more information.
So you know it mathematically speaking or in terms of information,
content,
it's just like the first way where you just say,
can I get in front of you without giving a reason?
So you should get 60% compliance.
But if people are automatically following a script and they'll let someone in,
because the script says if they give a reason,
let them in,
then it would have 90% compliance.
And sure enough they hadn't actually 93% compliance.
All you have to say is because I have five pages to xerox,
rather than not saying anything.
So is this an example of people not realizing that they're following a script
and they're in a social interaction?
A pro tip that y'all can walk away with?
I find that don't want just say,
yeah.
Um,
so,
so with respect to generating new ideas and so on,
you talked about,
um,
concept Iran.
What are those?
So you store information in the brain and it rob 2005,
there's some very interesting experiments done with people who had electrodes
implanted because they had intractable epilepsy.
So they had to take readings and their brain to see what,
what kind of surgical procedure to do.
And these neuroscientists,
uh,
you,
piggyback on,
on those people did experiments on them and they would show them pictures or
talk,
tell them names and they would see whether it's what would it stimulated within
the brain.
And they found that,
that the,
that the neural patterns for certain concepts or concepts period are,
are very sparse in the brain.
It's not a distributed over millions and millions of neurons,
but there are very specific neurons that respond to very specific concepts.
And they respond not just to the stimulus of let's say if it's a person or the
person's face or their image,
but the same neuron would wood,
that's why they're called constantly.
Neurons would respond to the very idea that person.
So Haley Berry was one you could see Haileybury straight on.
If they would fire from the side,
it would fire trust up in some weird superhero it,
it would fire just her name written up,
it would fire.
So these,
that's why they named concentrators,
they found that that concepts are represented sparsely by in different sets of
neurons in the brain.
And why that's important is when we make associations to get Amanda to
imaginative and creative ideas.
It's when different networks of concept neurons interact with each other and you
get combined to form a new concept.
Okay,
that makes sense.
And how it relates to last,
this city and so on.
You also,
um,
later on in the book you talk a little bit how sentences are like puzzles,
how our sentences like puzzles.
Well,
when you,
when you hear language,
you're hearing string of words,
but each word can have many different meanings depending on the context.
So when you are decoding what I say,
you're not your,
your brain is not translating.
If you,
the idea of what each word means,
as I go through the sentence,
it's actually waiting for the sentence to get finished.
And,
or if it's a long sense,
somewhere along the way,
when it has the right context,
it's doing a calculation to figure out for each word which of it's possible
meanings as the correct meeting.
So I'll see if I get the sentence right.
I have one in the book it said,
um,
the cooking teacher said the children made good snaps.
Okay.
Yeah.
They're like,
you guys are,
are no,
we're not going to say next because the other sentences the Cannibal said to the
children make good snacks.
So if I had given you that,
uh,
that,
that intro,
when you heard the sentence,
the children made good snap the cook.
If you just had the children make good snacks,
as your mind goes a lot,
the word mate came along,
it would have interpreted it one way.
And if I said the cannibal,
who would interpret it another way?
So every sentence like that,
it is a puzzle where you have a number of words that are,
have some order and each work and have the different possible meanings.
And your brain has to figure out what set of meetings for these words.
And you put together to make that sentence.
And should I let you ask another yeah.
Sites
just so
what the reason that's important is that to language researchers
were looking at what happens when people have strokes on,
on the right side of the brain.
And people had traditionally thought that the left side of the brain is
important.
This is Jack until it sort of 1950s and the early sixties and the right side,
they would say it's just a throwaway.
You don't really need it.
It's just there.
I don't know what they were thinking,
but basically that's what they said.
And,
and Roger Sperry,
who you may have heard of thought that that would be ridiculous if you wanted to
know what the real difference was between them.
And he realized that by a jury,
people with stroke,
she couldn't really,
or other brain damage the watch list or the other,
it wasn't controlled enough to really tell.
He started cutting through the Corpus callosum of,
um,
the animals to separate the right and the left brain.
And then he designed experiments,
um,
that would address just the right side or the love.
Just the left side of the brain and you can do that because your sense is also
go through the right there also that arise so that you can,
you can present either auditory signals or visual signals to one side or the
other and then you can make tests to see if I teach the right side of the brain
something cause the left side,
no it and he found that there are basically two independent information
processors,
which was very controversial because might imagine if you believe in a soul,
what does that mean?
You're two souls or two people or what does it mean?
But he ended up getting a Nobel prize for it and yet it didn't have quite the
impact that maybe it should have through the years and people still were,
we're kind of tending to dismiss the right side of the brain and the left side
is the one that's known for language.
But these two researchers who Nielsen Beeman,
we're looking at the deficits that people had who had rights side strokes and
they were very interesting.
They were,
they had trouble understanding metaphors and they had trouble understanding
jokes.
He would tell them a joke today if we didn't think it was funny,
which usually if I told you
some fraction of the thought that when you choose whether or not the left.
So what they were saying was,
okay,
well how does this relate to if a language is,
if language is like a puzzle,
what does this mean?
And they eventually through a lot of experimentation and thought,
and they came to the conclusion that when you hear a sentence or when you see a
puzzle,
your brain or when you're at work and you run into a problem,
you have to solve right here with your brain starts throwing up ideas,
associations as to how he might approach it herself.
The problem,
and these are all being at first.
Dot.
On a subconscious level and not all of them enter your consciousness.
Then there are various filters,
circuits in your brain that work together to determine what reaches your
consciousness.
This is also the same way that,
uh,
you,
you have inhibition of your behavior.
So a few,
if you walked by,
um,
the cafeteria and you're hungry and you see a French fries,
your brain is giving you the idea to grab the French,
right?
And your brain is also censoring that idea cause it's probably not,
not a good idea to walk by and grab food from other people's tables.
Right.
And in the book,
I tell a story about my dad had a stroke and that power of his brain and he
would grab the French fries,
you know,
he would get the idea and you would do it.
Well that's bad because we need these filters.
We need them to keep us from doing stuff like that.
Or if you're on the second floor,
don't just jump out the window,
take the stairs.
And you don't want crazy ideas when you're trying to solve the problem either.
Or you get too many crazy ideas and you get nowhere.
On the other hand,
sometimes the crazy idea is the one that solves the problem.
And if your brain is too conventional,
it filters out all those ideas,
then you're not going to solve a problem.
He never going to have a creative thought.
You never going to innovate.
So it's all a balance in the idea of in the last tick thinking is how to tune
this balance for yourself.
So what Cuny Olson Beaman realized was that the right side of your brain,
certain structure and the right side of your brain is producing these more odd
ideas.
And on your left side of the brain is bruising in the more conventional ideas.
And then these different structures in your brain are choosing what to bring to
your consciousness.
And so a metaphor is based on an interpretation of a word.
You are the light of my life.
Well I don't really mean that I,
that I can't see unless you're in the room or if you tell a joke it,
it,
it usually does not depend on the literal meaning of what's going on in depends
upon making some jobs.
So your right side of your brain is understanding of proposing these ideas and
your left side of the more conventional ones.
So the people who who had the,
the,
the brain damage on the right side.
We're not getting these more,
they call the remote associations only the more usual association.
So they could understand jokes and metaphors,
but they realize this is a part of a much broader theme,
which is that your ideas in general come that way.
When you're solving any puzzle in life,
not just the sentence in,
in,
in the language.
You're right inside of their brain is proposing the more I've solutions or ideas
or thoughts in the left side,
the more conventional ones and your filters and your brain,
different brain structures are sorting through that.
Yeah.
Related to the remote associations.
You brought up this instance of these researchers who had compound remote
association problems,
which
they didn't quite abbreviated like that,
right?
But
Tom town
today,
they didn't want,
I mean,
a lot of scientific papers have that in them,
but no scientist wants to actually use that word.
So they called him the crs.
Probably a wise move.
I think one example you gave was,
um,
pine crab in sauce was one of the examples.
Here's the,
here's the puzzle.
There was another word that goes with each of those.
So if you think of,
um,
conferences,
it's the wrong one,
ones pine cone,
but not so Costco,
right?
So it's pine crap and sauce.
That's one of their puzzles.
So there's two ways to solve that puzzle.
Just like,
just to have the two ways of thinking.
You could analytically start running through words in your mind,
may have some heuristic about what kind of words to run through.
Or You may start with one of them like pine and do those words and then check
each one with the other next word and then checked out the next word.
Or You sit there and you go and then it comes to you,
right?
That's called insight.
They call it said,
so what they were studying was it different ways that our brain works doing one
versus the other.
And they also,
one of the ways that they could tell what parts of your brain are doing web is
they would,
um,
image your brain while you were doing that.
And sometimes they would use something called transcranial stimulation,
which disrupts part of your brain.
So you could actually,
electronic could disrupt certain structures in your brain.
And southern people are solving these problems a lot better than they than they
were when one case there was a very experienced meditator who was so it focus
that he couldn't stop any of these profits if it was kind of embarrassed and
that he,
this is very important,
less than the book.
He was able to see that and changed his thinking,
has changed his approach,
relax and open up his left,
his filters go away and open up his mind.
And then he did.
Southern did better than other people were generally did.
And these researchers said in all the years of of presenting these problems,
no one ever had a switch like that.
So it's possible to take charge of your brain and the way you think.
And to throw in one more random comment on that,
it's very interesting that they could see in their subjects,
brace through,
through the,
um,
the,
the use both f MRI and EEG.
They could tell,
um,
about five or six seconds before the subject,
even south of the,
uh,
the,
the problem.
And even before they knew what the problem was,
which way they would do it,
whether it was analytical or or elastic.
And the subjects didn't realize that they,
that they have predetermined in their brain what they were going to do,
but they were in one mindset or another.
So they were either in an analytical mindset or an elastic mindset by reading
the brains to the experiments,
can tell which one it was.
And then when they asked him afterwards,
how did you solve the problem,
they were right about whether it was this letting the thing come to you or the
analytical thinking.
Has anyone by the way stop?
So was that the words were,
I don't want to say crap time.
So to be clear,
you have to cut with one word that pairs with each of these
give me be before and after it.
So pine crowd and sauce.
And did you get that
bye logically reasoning or did it just come to you?
Okay.
That's a good way to get.
So we talk about,
I've talked a lot about in the book about the ways that you can,
you know,
help that.
And I think that Google having a gym here as a great thing because that's one
way,
you know,
when you're thinking very enough,
very focused manner,
you need to get rid of the e that's good to do it,
to analyze a problem,
then you want to let that go and stop thinking about it.
Get on the treadmill,
do something that really,
you know,
takes you away.
It doesn't let you think about your grocery list or would you have to do at home
or that problem and then things will come to you or the taking the nap.
Do you have a little nap rooms?
That's a great thing.
I see that they,
they understand this here.
So
yeah.
I like how you do that.
You talked about,
um,
I guess these different modes of thinking and how they can apply to different
situations.
And I think even in the book you talked about how you take advantage of that
during the day.
Can you tell us a little bit about that?
One thing is that,
uh,
your,
your filters kind of to relax when you are exhausted,
mentally exhausted.
So you might be a morning person or an evening person,
but whatever it is,
one of the best times street is two.
Two if you needed to find creative solutions is to do it when,
when your analytical mind is just kept doing anymore.
So they,
they do experiments where they'd have people saw these really boring
analytic thinking problems,
a little arithmetic problems or puzzles and,
and afterwards they give them a problem that requires some creativity and they
do better than the people who were relaxing just to go into the TAC.
The,
you know,
the problem that way.
So that's one thing you can do.
I mean,
another thing is to realize that,
uh,
is to realize that it's good to stop and,
and just take a break.
And when you're taking a break or you know,
like laying on the couch,
staring at the ceiling,
you're not necessarily goofing off.
You're legitimately letting your mind works so you can legitimately be working.
I consider yourself at work.
You're laying down there.
That's good to know.
I found this great story about on what it,
she,
uh,
he had his Katrin's who would see him take a break and they were not paying you
all this money.
I want you to keep working.
I wanted to keep working.
He argued with them,
but no,
when I take a break that is working.
So that's a,
that's a good,
you know,
if your supervisor doesn't know that,
but just say,
hey,
you got the an hour working for you now
and remember these because just like earlier,
right?
Because right.
The couch,
I need to solve this problem.
Not because I'm taking it out.
Um,
so I'm going to keep asking questions,
but if any of you have questions related to last to or me how to activate it and
so on,
feel free to line up at the mic and we'll start to mix those in as time goes on.
Um,
and if not,
you'll just get to hear Mike repaired questions the whole time and put all the
pressure on me.
Yeah,
so
fortunately I haven't been down,
so we've already activated that part in the book.
You also mentioned your collaboration with the late Stephen Hawking.
Um,
what,
what did he teach you about elastic thinking?
Well,
many things.
I think one of the most unusual things was,
uh,
because of the way he communicated,
we had to interact in a very unusual manner.
So he imposed his sentences.
He had to first,
he would,
uh,
when I first started working with them,
he wouldn't use his thumb to click a mouse in later.
Yeah.
Emotion sensor on his glasses that would read one his cheek tours and that would
be like a mouse click and on his computer screen and cursor was flying around.
There'd be rolls of letters first row,
second row.
So we capture let's say the second row,
then it will start moving across each letter.
You can capture a letter.
Once he had a letter,
it gave him a choice of words or even do a second letter and then it gets a
choice of words with those two letters,
et cetera.
And it was about six words a minute that he could do that way.
So we were working together even closer to this and be like,
no table there,
you know,
and he would be typing out of sentences and that first time zoning out and I'm
going,
Oh wow,
okay.
I'm,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm daydreaming and um,
but then I,
you know,
I eventually realized that very soon realized I could,
I could see on his screen what he's writing.
I could,
it would,
it would show and had he had,
he would push,
you would cook something and there with a computer voice would pronounce it,
but you can watch him composing his,
his senses.
And I would,
you know,
look over her shoulder and I would start thinking about what he was saying.
So it's really interesting.
And sometimes if I knew what what he was saying,
I wouldn't say,
Oh,
you're saying blah,
blah,
blah.
But sometimes I was just letting it go even though I knew what it was because I
had that I could think about.
So as we're talking,
I'm not thinking very much.
It was,
it's probably pretty automatic year.
When you say something with a fixed action pattern,
you say something that triggers my brain to something in the book and I'm just
reading the book to you guys.
So,
so,
but you know,
but in most conversations it's pretty immediate.
You don't talk to somebody and then you're not going to wait for four minutes
for you with your friends.
Wait for him as for you to say something.
I mean it was stolen maybe,
but not juggling.
So this was a,
this was different,
our conversations then,
at least from my side,
right,
very different because I could,
I would think more deeply about what we were talking about also kind of the time
to figure out what it's talking about because it might go pretty fast.
But it's,
it's a very,
it's an important thing because quite often we don't think deeply enough where
when you take the first one,
the answer that you get at something,
and that's not the creative answer,
that's let's say the,
it gets their answer,
but not the best answer.
Right.
And if you would only stop and say,
no,
I want something better and not just accept that answer that you would get
better ideas.
And there was a good experiment in the book,
but they talking about what's chess players and they give,
so who,
who you get,
who here plays chest?
So the chest playing crowd,
well you know they have these magazines or on our websites,
it could be chess puzzles as a board position.
And they say,
can you know,
how do you check made forest checkmate in three moves or five moves.
So they give you the board position and your,
your problem is to figure out how you can given your white,
let's say forced and it's your move force your opponent into a checkmate and
they give a number of moves.
So they design a nice situation where there was a easy solution to took five
rules and there was a very clever solution.
It took three moves.
That was so that's considered better.
And they,
they gave this to a lot of different chess players to solve and they,
and they correlated the,
how could the chess player was.
And according to their master points.
So that's something we're rating system they haven't chest to,
to whether they could solve this problem and that there's some of the people
they would,
they would show the the easiest solution first.
Um,
no,
I'm sorry.
Some people will be given the board or the,
or the easiest solution was not present and others would be given the board that
the problem where the easy on that Harvard were both present and what they found
was that they were really good.
The,
the,
the experts at solving the hard problem when it UC would stop getting to the
heart solution when the easy one wasn't there.
But one of the easy one was there and they of course would immediately answer
it.
They were a lot worse it,
they would not find that hard one.
And they did some statistical correlations and found that it was like a quilted,
I think two 300 master points or something.
So I mean that's a huge different in chefs difference in chess.
I forgot I said in the book it's like an Iq difference between 90 and 120 or
something like that.
I mean it really doesn't.
Knowing knowing the easy answer make people a lot dumber and finding the
creative more creative answers.
So just something to think about.
I really liked that aspect of the book that you had in various problems there.
We talked about wowing them with the,
with the crowd,
the pine and the sauce.
We talked about the chess one.
You also have various little quizzes where you can measure how um,
how hoping you are to do experiences in,
in their other quizzes like that.
I liked that aspect of it a lot that you have these various indirect things.
Hi,
can you hear me?
Yes.
Cool.
I have a question about how to reward elastic thinking because you know,
he means a kind of a reward Trevon animal,
but most of our reward system is trying to be really analytical so they track
your performance over time.
You can have a metric about it and that's how you get a reward for it because
the metrics showed that you did well but fall creativity or ls to Citi does,
it doesn't seem there are.
So at least I don't know,
a good way of saying,
oh you did good in that and therefore I can reward you and hope that you'll
continue to do more elastic thinking.
So yeah,
that's a great question.
And we could do a whole hour on that and as you can tell him,
my boss tends to keep going.
But um,
so there are two kinds of rewards that people who study this talking about
extrinsic rewards and intrinsic rewards.
So you bring has a reward system that I talked on the book that rewards you when
you do some certain things.
And those are by definition the things you liked,
right?
To be here.
I haven't seen it.
Does three things you like to do you like to do them because it's rewarding.
It would kind of works together.
And then there's money and um,
uh,
Bonnie related things that,
you know,
gifts or,
I don't want to say praise because praise is kind of in between,
but what they,
what psychologists have found is that the extrinsic rewards are not really good
at,
they can eat quite counterproductive.
Now they,
if they tell you you have to finish writing this code by Monday,
uh,
and you know,
it's really important to the company,
it will give you 10 grand.
If you do it,
you'll probably do it.
Right.
So for short term,
very well defined things,
it's,
uh,
it,
you know,
it tends to work.
People,
it's your conscious mind takes over and they,
they do it more long term and,
and,
and less define things like,
are you forensics is going to be a better employee if you're rewarded monetarily
that doesn't really follow.
Um,
and the more creative the task you're doing is the last important or even the
more negative.
The monetary reward is,
I actually quote Dostoyevsky who wasn't a psychologist,
but he was complaining that he,
what?
This hellish Simon,
he had to write this novel.
Yeah,
I forgot what novel was,
but uh,
and um,
and how would I torture it was,
and when you hear that you go,
oh my God,
I didn't realize that he rolled on Spec like that where someone says,
write about,
you know,
and it wasn't at all,
it was just to write a novel.
The assignment was just to write it down,
but he was big payday that,
you know,
being,
he had a contract to write the novel for him that totally killed his creativity
as loss.
Maybe an extreme example,
but that's the tendency of what happens.
They send people,
the researchers have found that when you pay people that give her this extrinsic
motivation test to interfere with the creativity,
but the intrinsic motivation,
which comes from you,
which is Google saying to you,
what do you like?
Let's assign you to do that.
Let's,
let's put you in the,
in the area that,
that you'd like to do.
And if you later on one change to be open to saying when your mom moved over
there,
I do that.
That's intrinsic motivation that comes and it's deeper within from within your
own brain and that that is very important and very effective.
Um,
I'm going to call back just a moment ago.
You've mentioned somebody potentially being stoned.
It came up,
it came up in your book as well being stone.
It's legal in this state.
How does,
how does being stone really to elastic thinking?
That's the cure for everything.
Um,
so marijuana,
well,
okay.
Alcohol also,
uh,
and marijuana and certain psychedelic drugs.
Uh,
I always show,
uh,
they act on those filters I was talking about.
So that's just a chemical way of,
of loosening those filters and allowing more creative ideas to go through it.
Now I,
I should say what I do in the book,
so they all have their own downsides.
Uh,
I don't just mean,
you know,
you get drunk and you could walk through a window.
But,
um,
I mean,
I mean more objectively that marijuana has other effects on your brain,
your short term memory,
hard to keep things in your working memory.
I don't know if you've ever had that experience where your stone then you forget
what you were saying.
I mean,
I get that,
not that I ever have [inaudible]
so,
um,
so that can compete also for lot of things.
You need that executive function to guide your thinking and so the thoughts are
coming,
but there's no guidance and so you're,
you know,
detached from reality and,
and so there are these different
aides that you might try a,
the end that many artists and musicians swear by,
they have their plus sides and they're monocytes and you have to use,
uh,
you know,
intelligently if you're using it for that purpose if you're not used to anyway
one.
Yeah,
using,
drinking to help.
The thing thinking reminds me of that quote from the character and game of
Thrones.
That's what I do.
I drink and I know things and it seems,
um,
anyway.
Do we have another question?
I'm curious,
kind of the difference between the,
I've heard it talked about it was like to subconscious background processing
thinking versus elastic thinking.
Like a,
you read a riddle right before you go to bed and then you wake up and you either
dreamed about the answer or are you just kind of the answer hit you out of
nowhere?
Or is this the same thing as like the shower epiphany that a lot of people have,
they're all that they're all related swimming when you're,
you have a problem that you set up analytically in your head,
but the answer is not,
it's not an algorithm bay.
A product of an algorithm.
The answer is let's say changing your is changing the way you set up the
problem.
For instance,
changing your assumptions
or changing the paradigm where you know it's more like you guys are starting use
these neural nets,
which I think is that the,
the the key to success in computer science.
So,
and I wrote a paper in the eighties so that's elastic thinking,
the neuro nuts with a neuroma,
not so you don't know how it got to the answer right?
You set it up till it,
the computer's doing this crazy stuff and it's learning and at the end you don't
know what algorithm it used in his brain to get the answer.
And that's the same thing with humans.
So when you get these ideas from the bottom up,
it's your neural nets in your brain doing some calculation,
giving you the answer.
It's not some algorithm saying do this,
then do this and then do that.
So yeah,
that's really the big,
big difference is that,
um,
one of the big differences is that I don't look,
but thinking tends to be top down and elastic thing.
He tends to be bottom up calculation
talking about the neural nets and so on.
It's kind of interesting because I think it was mentioned that the season or the
time that you wrote for the next generation,
y'all,
we're exploring some things around data and how much she was thinking also.
And that kind of,
it's a similar idea I suppose.
Yeah.
What,
what,
because we have the very naive concept of data that,
you know,
or like Spock was half of like that piece.
So it's kind of the same role where this is totally logical and rational.
But in reality,
somebody who was told or a beat or a thing that's totally like Roshes rational
and logical was never going to solve anything or do,
I mean,
first of all,
they won't even get started because if something is rational and logical,
he usually needs to be told to do something and then it can do that task.
But something that that is,
uh,
you know,
bottom up thinking or has emotional content,
which is why you have a reward center in your brain and you have emotions,
is to get you to realize that you should,
if you start doing something.
So in reality,
if data was purely a computer would sit there and wait to be given a problem
then and then he would answer it.
Right.
So
I think that,
um,
police in a little bit to,
to some of the other topics you talk about when you mentioned,
um,
choice overload,
for example,
what is choice overload?
Well,
so in today's society,
we have a lot of options for everything.
You go to the grocery store and there's 40 different kinds of touch with for or
cereal.
This one,
a researcher I talked about did a survey reported how many of each different
progress in the grocery store and it was um,
it was,
yeah,
yeah.
These are the kinds of things that can exhaust your brain and that can get you
on these loops that are not productive.
And what psychologists have found was that there's,
I don't want to say two kinds of people because that's what my stupid,
at least there's two ends of a one dimensional spectrum and one end they call
the maximizers.
These are miserable people
who wants to optimize and maximize the utility on the economics of everything.
So when I presented with 40 different kinds of mayonnaise,
I will spend an hour analyzing each one.
It's trying to figure out what,
you know,
which one is better than the other one,
even though it really doesn't matter.
Right.
Or it doesn't matter much at the other end are the Sabbath Spicer's they call up
who as soon as they find the first one that that works,
take that one of their and very happily.
So that's,
that's what I recommend.
Well let's think about that again.
I find it interesting when you were talking about the creative thinking and you
related to schizophrenia,
Schizo typic personality traits.
How are those two
intertwined?
So skits people get onto both of schizotypal use or schizo.
Tippy is a,
is a,
uh,
a trait that is related to schizophrenia.
So again,
if you think of a spectrum,
there'd be people who are far to one end are schizophrenia.
And then there are people with different traits,
different degrees of that.
And that has to do with how attached you are to reality.
And,
and do you have,
tend to have a tendency toward odd and magical thinking.
So based on what I've said so far,
you can imagine that this has to do with some of the filters in your brain and
to getting new ideas.
So people who are near the schizophrenia side can often be extremely creative.
Well,
I should say it's not really creative,
but extremely good at idea generation and generating novel divergent ideas.
They're not really often very creative because that also takes some analytical
thinking to channel and figure out what you need and put everything together.
So this is an interesting trait to look at.
Cause it's a way,
it's a measure of your filters and when your filters are too low,
then you're detached from reality.
But if it filters are too high,
then you're so conventional that you'll never have a new idea.
And that still has its place,
um,
more more so than the other side in society.
But,
but it's a very important aspect of the last thinking.
Yeah.
And it struck me as kind of tragic.
I mean these people,
some,
some people who are right on the border,
I think you referenced the,
yeah,
John Nash,
he was on the border for years and was,
uh,
enough reality based to the work that got a Nobel prize.
And then he went over the edge and he was schizophrenia for some years and then
he recovered.
Right.
Yeah.
We have another question.
So,
um,
I'm actually,
uh,
an improviser as well.
It's somebody here.
And so like it seems to me like in that role,
like I get my own way to practice some of this creative thinking that I wouldn't
get if I just did work.
Um,
are there other ways that you've seen,
um,
that work to help people get this more creative aspect of themselves or
train their brain to be more elastic thinking?
Yeah.
So I talked about different things you can do.
One is meditation and often meditation related exercises that make you more
mindful.
So one of the important things to be as mindful of how are you attacking a
problem and when you're getting to a barrier and once good to stop and take
another approach and,
and,
and to be mindful of yourself and to know what is it that you do that can,
that can help do that.
Um,
uh,
another thing is it's very important to overcome the fear of failure.
I don't know how Google was about that,
but some companies,
if you screw off of the whatever bad review or you know,
your project failed or he did something that didn't work and you get criticized
for that and you know,
they,
they make you afraid to fail,
which is a very,
um,
you know,
it's a creativity killer.
As a theoretical physicist,
I know that almost every idea I have sucks.
And sometimes,
you know,
the only question is,
is it take me five minutes or 50 days to figure out that it sucks,
you know,
and then you go through a lot of those and eventually you get one,
it doesn't,
then you publish something,
you know,
but,
but if you're afraid to make that jump,
or even when I,
when I'm writing as the same way,
I mean,
I write a lot of stuff that's stupid and four,
I just hope that I have noticed that before I publish the book and take it out
and somebody tells me.
But if I was afraid to write something that was stupid,
I would never write anything that was interesting either.
I would just write a textbook.
So,
um,
I think that's another thing and work on your fear of failure and one,
you know,
I know that you have that problem.
I think it's very important to fail.
Talk about how you failed.
Think about when you think about what other people failed.
Um,
you know,
open up about it and get used to like write,
learn how to ski.
I realized soon that the first thing I do when I got to this,
he saw this fall over because I was scape really stiff,
but I didn't want to fall over.
And I,
you know,
and I was getting badly because I was afraid to fall.
But if I fall immediately,
I get that over with us.
Not so bad.
I would fall today,
I'm not going to have a fall free date and then I could really scheme.
And it's the same thing with failure.
So it's good to fail it,
used to it and embrace it,
enjoy it.
The more you fail,
the more success you'll have,
right?
Just keep doing it or the more statistically speaking,
I'm not saying that failure is a success.
Um,
so that's another,
another thing you can do.
Oh,
argue with people arguing is very good.
Talk to people who totally disagree with you are very different.
If you hate,
you know,
if you're a very confessional,
either go to the weirdest restaurant,
you can travel.
I mean all these things that they've shown you increased your elastic thinking.
They've even shown him that he was an interesting experiment.
They had people in a room and they had these um,
uh,
paint chips and some are red,
some are green and some are blue.
And they had,
they'd have like 10 people in the room.
One was a confederate,
a associate of the researcher because if you ever in a psych experiment and all
of that,
that's number one.
They tell you that every one speaks to me as a screener blue and they say blue,
blue,
and then this confront,
it was like green.
I,
it was obviously blue,
but he would say,
great.
Okay.
That was the experiment.
So that they told people we're going to be,
you're going to be the second unrelated experiment.
Well if they have a psychotic or it tells you that,
just laugh,
laugh in her face,
you know.
And um,
so the second experiment supposedly unrelated was safe.
Give you these paint chips to categorize.
Now they're all on the spectrum between blue and green.
So you know,
you could,
there's what,
there's a continuous spectrum of,
uh,
of frequencies between blue and green.
And they would give her these paint chips and you have to say what your limits
are bringing.
Well,
guess what?
Even though the people who saw the,
the guy and that other experiment he called whatever I said,
you called the blue chip green and they thought that was stupid.
It was really blue when they are now categorizing these chips,
you know,
and all the kinds of where you draw a line between green and blue.
Well,
the ones who saw that guy who said that green was blue drew the line,
you know,
much closer to blue poppy must have made the,
made the blue section much bigger than the ones who didn't,
who weren't in that.
So,
even though this person's ridiculous statement,
it didn't seem to influence some,
they were influenced suddenly later on their judgements.
So even when you,
someone says something that you totally disagree with and you go,
that's really stupid.
It can,
it can actually have an effect on your thinking.
But I'm in a positive,
effective can expand your thinking and the kinds of possibilities that you,
that you think about.
So,
um,
yeah,
we'll have some more of this raspberries.
Yeah.
Well we'll wrap up with this.
Um,
you have various bits of wisdom from your parents in the book.
I read something about a worm in horseradish.
You'll have to read the book to know more about that.
Um,
and from your mother,
you have the phrase of where there's a will,
there's a way.
How does this relate to being elastic?
What this has to do with what I was talking about,
failure and about how sometimes the best elastic making comes from when you
don't accept what you see or when you don't accept that you're not going to get
there and you just,
and you just keep trying.
So the idea is that if you broaden your perspective and the amount of the,
the,
um,
broaden the range of ideas that you find that you'll consider,
or that your brain poses to you,
you have a much greater chance of solving a problem even though you think that
it can't possibly be solved.
Well,
thank you very much.
[inaudible].